hola I am The Green Hornet and I would
like to sit down with your boss you have
one of the most drastic transformations
in Hollywood Seth Rogen we remember you
as the funny guy who was a little
overweight in the early 2000s but in
recent years you've undergone a massive
transformation it's hard to recognize
you and we are seriously impressed with
the change but you definitely aren't the
only star who has put in the work and
completely transformed their body
celebrities in Hollywood often lose a
lot of weight leaving them almost
unrecognizable stay tuned to find out
which actors weight-loss wasn't
necessarily a good thing here are 10
celebrities who we barely recognized
after they shed those pounds Jennifer
Hudson is currently on everyone's radar
after her performance and cats no matter
how people feel about the movie fans and
critics agree that her voice and acting
were sublime Jennifer first ended up in
Hollywood after her stint on American
Idol she was a lovely plus-sized singer
who quickly proved her talent as an
actress she even won an Academy Award
for dream girls in her early days that
Jennifer was a size 16 but over the last
several years she has lost a lot of
weight and kept it off she takes a
really healthy approach to weight loss
she focuses on how her body feels
instead of what the scale says so she
doesn't know exactly how many pounds
she's lost the number is somewhere over
80 pounds though she is really busy so
her main way to control her weight is
diet and portion control getting into
the rhythm of regular exercise is
difficult when you're both a Grammy and
Oscar winner
she wears around to size six these days
she's still got a show-stopping singing
voice and is an awesome person which is
what really matters
[Music]
he might be most famous for his role in
Superbad but Jonah Hill was acting long
before that in the early 2000s Jonah was
often typecast as the overweight funny
sidekick or best friend and he is
definitely hilarious it was hard to
imagine him as anything else
you certainly but Jonah now looks
completely different he set out on a
weight loss journey several years ago he
started shedding the weight for the
movie Moneyball
but his physique became even more toned
after that Jonah put in a lot of hard
work to get his current body he met with
the nutritionist who helped him carve
out a healthy diet it's important to
lose weight in a healthy way with the
help of medical professionals that's why
Jonah has been able to keep the pounds
off he said the biggest change was
cutting out beer which he loved he also
works out with the help of physical
trainers as his body changed so did his
career he has taken on several more
serious roles and has earned some Oscar
nominations but he's still one funny
dude Millennials will remember the
hugely popular Nickelodeon show Drake
and Josh
Josh Peck played the character Josh
Nichols on this show about two boys who
become brothers Josh was such a funny
character and he is one of the most
beloved Nickelodeon stars of all time he
was big for his age in fact he was
nearly 300 pounds
Josh admits that he wasn't living a
healthy lifestyle and he didn't really
like his image he also realized that he
was now a role model for a lot of kids
he set out to lose weight for both
himself and his fans although he was a
candidate for weight loss surgery he
wanted to tone up which his diet and
exercise and he definitely did he worked
really hard at the gym and changed his
eating habits he also shot up four
inches and finished puberty which helps
even out his body proportions now Josh
looks like a totally different guy it
gets a little annoying hearing people
comment on his body all the time but he
feels a lot better and is glad that he
inspired so many kids Anthony Anderson
has been acting for almost three decades
and he can act in just about any genre
he's done comedy drama and even action
movies the actor from blackish spent a
lot of his career as a big guy he's only
five foot ten and at his heaviest
weighed 270 pounds it never affected his
self-confidence though he's never really
struggled with body image issues the
wake-up call came from his doctor in his
early 30s he was diagnosed with type 2
diabetes
that's a pretty young age for that
disease diabetes can cause lots of major
health issues so Anthony decided to get
serious he has adopted a mostly vegan
diet because it keeps him healthier he
also got a lot more active but it
doesn't do a lot of boring exercises
besides running he enjoys riding his
bike and playing basketball
Anthony definitely looks a lot different
these days it's always admirable to see
people take their health issues
seriously and change their realities we
know his doctors it must be really happy
with him not all weight loss is healthy
or sustainable and Lucy Mecklenburgh is
a perfect example Lucy is a British
model and reality star she got her fame
from starring on the reality show The
Only Way Is Essex has a model Lucy had a
great figure she was naturally thin
which matched her petite frame but she
was really healthy Lucy gained
international fame when she went on
celebrity Island with bare gorillas in
2017 she and other celebs were forced to
rough it up with the famous survivalist
over the course of the show
Lucy lost 28 pounds but since she was
already so small this was not a healthy
weight loss she was exposed to the
elements and doing intense physical
activity all day she also got in the
habit of eating less because of the
nature of the show the reality series
took a huge emotional and physical toll
on Lucy she was appalled at her weight
loss after the show she barely
recognized herself thankfully through
eating more nutrient-dense foods she put
the weight back on
Kirstie Alley has been around Hollywood
for a long time and she was a
full-figured actor for the majority of
her career her weight has gone up and
down over the years she even made a show
called fat actress which was loosely
based on her career as a plus-size star
in 2004 Kirstie became the celebrity
spokesperson for Jenny Craig the popular
diet plan helped her lose a lot of
weight but when she stops Jenny Craig
the weight came back Kirstie really
wanted to lose the weight and keep it
off
so she challenged herself she signed up
for Dancing with the Stars to hold
herself accountable to get ready for the
show
she lost 60 pounds through the course of
all the dance training she lost another
30
she has also learned which two foods are
her trigger foods that encourage
unhealthy eating by avoiding clam
linguini and cheese she's able to stick
to healthier choices Kirstie is doing a
great job of keeping her excess weight
off I actually I live a very happy life
which Hollywood hunk lost a ton of
weight for a role keep watching to find
out the comedy king of the early 2000s
has had a dramatic transformation he got
his start on the teen show Freaks and
Geeks that's where his image as the
chubby funny guy started he was famous
for movies like knocked up and pineapple
Express and Seth wasn't a small guy in
these roles he underwent his first
weight loss journey for the 2011 film
The Green Hornet he worked with a
dietician and physical trainer to lose
over 30 pounds drastic diet changes can
be harmful so he was still able to eat
five times a day but he ate
nutrient-dense foods and cut down on
sugary treats Seth still wasn't really
thin by Hollywood standards until a few
years ago then he started toning up in
may 20 19 he appeared on the cover of GQ
magazine fans noticed he looked totally
different he has a slender physique
these days and we are impressed
Seth's showed off his new bod in a tux
at the Lion King premiere I bust through
the border and I'm a free man that's all
I kept thinking man it seems like some
of the funniest men in Hollywood started
out on the heavier side Zach
Galifianakis has been acting for a while
but he became really famous in the 2009
movie The Hangover he played the lovable
simple-minded Alan Zach was known for
his humor and
his looks it's a different story these
days lots of experts will tell you that
the best way to lose weight is to do it
slowly it's how you can really keep the
weight off in the future
Zack took this to heart he started his
weight-loss journey in 2013 at first he
didn't make any drastic changes in fact
he has said the biggest change he had to
make was cutting back on drinking
he loved beer and vodka she also really
enjoyed eating sausages by avoiding
these things he started to drop the
weight his weight loss was gradual but
when he showed up on the red carpet in
2017 fans were shocked it was easy to
see how much weight he had lost he toned
up and now he looks amazing Alan this is
an intervention Oh what okay we know
she's not really an actress like the
others but pop singer Adele has one of
the most dramatic weight loss stories
ever she released her debut album back
in 2008 and was an overnight success
Adele has always been a plus-sized star
her fame was all about her beautiful
music and her charming relatable
personality but recently she has lost
over 100 pounds she said it was really
three simple changes that led to this
dramatic transformation first she
improved her diet after her child was
born she made healthier food choices
which helped a lot second she gave up
some of her vices to protect her voice
she stopped drinking sugary drinks and
she gave up drinking and smoking and for
a time she even cut down on caffeine
that's impressive
but we know she's much healthier for it
finally she took up Pilates it's a great
exercise for people who haven't worked
out a lot she hired a celebrity Pilates
trainer who says she wasn't even aware
it was Adele at first alright alright
alright it's time for the most drastic
weight loss of all Matthew McConaughey
has always been known for having an
ideal Hollywood body he's always been
super toned and muscular but Matthew was
also a great actor who totally commits
to his roles in 2012 he starred in
Dallas buyers club he played an AIDS
patient and he needed to lose a lot of
weight he dropped all the way down to
143 pounds on his tall figure that is
super skinny it was shocking
he changed his diet and exercised even
more he found that his eating habits
affected the scale a lot more than
exercise did in fact he says it was 90%
diet Matthew didn't look anything like
the heart drop that everyone knows it
wasn't the healthiest weight loss but it
helped earned him an Oscar he wouldn't
have been nearly as believable in the
role if he hadn't been so thin
after the role matthew bulked up back to
his usual weight which is in the 180
pound range
Fugazi it's a fake which celebrity do
you think had the most drastic
transformation tell us in the comment
section below
that's a wrap give this video a big
thumbs up thanks for watching and we'll
see you next time